[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on Saucon very
excited to be talking about artificial
intelligence applications and so much
more
we have chip we and joining us on the
show hello yes so excited
likewise super pumped for this I'm so
grateful that we we've I ran into your
beautiful world word clouds that you
were showcasing on your Twitter profile
and on your website and I was like these
are really profound and I'm excited to
share them they give us really good
insights and so we'll be getting to that
during the episode of pump for that
those that don't know chip Wiens
background she's an applied research
engineer who created the tensorflow
course at Stanford a four times
vietnamese best-selling author and works
a lot with data and you can find who yen
ship comm link in the bio as well as the
twitter profile which is ISAT amazing in
the words like it just doesn't be male
officer introducer when I go somewhere
high man I'm an Forge it all always yeah
that's right well we've got to get
people excited because you're very
important to share what you're doing and
with the world and that's why you're
here with us yeah let's start things off
by asking you what are your thoughts on
the direction of our world man this is
such a like big question so so actually
so funny and I Granick was on my left
here
I was talking to drive her to the driver
about this and he was like people keep
talking about how bad things have been
but actually he's like he's in 60s right
it was like actually it was a lot worse
before so lazy a lot of bad things
happening but like overall I look into
the overall progress like things are
getting better over time so I think like
the world is getting better
yeah yeah a lot of people say that the
world is getting better across so many
different domains and it's very true and
in other regards the complexity of our
exponential technology energy of
politics our and our spiritual wisdom is
not really caught up to that and so yeah
what do you think about that I wish you
ain't worried so you look like soul of a
lot of scientific advances are like to
really truly help everyone still know
like vaccine antibiotics but like even
look at historical evidence well it has
shown that easily
people who hold the right technologies
have an ash over or I can use so
technologies against those who don't you
look like on slavery colonization it's
just people with big ship with like gun
power can I overpower other countries so
I shouldn't really worried about it
because I don't have a feel like so I'm
from Vietnam a very tiny country and the
only way I'm doing a lot of oh don't
still don't know what what I is about I
didn't know it is a hyper word
everyone's talking about it but I what
what is it about where as people here
everyone knows what it is and I'm
honestly trying to agents for a business
I must really worried at one day but
then I is from all I technology in
general I don't make the gap even more
even bigger some Vietnam of countries I
mean I have no chance am i competing
like both commercially or militarily
with other with more developed countries
when the gap gets bigger
yeah the network effect is so strong and
the United States and China and other
leaders and field are potentially going
to take off at faster rates with
technology and then
how do we make sure that it's
it's a very difficult thing to figure
out and we gotta have humanity I think
it's good it's good that people are
looking into it
we always safety my regular
regularization it's just that a lot of
it is still very western-centric so I
think a good low to seem more like
diverse voice in how she make AI not
really safe for Malia beneficial shoe
she only people in the developed nations
where it'll actually then if I showed
you everyone as well yeah there's
moralities and philosophies and ethical
codes from around the world in other
countries that could be applied to the
way that the west and the way that China
is making AI yeah to make it be
inclusive AI and sharing the PI growth
not just with making trillionaires but
with yeah yeah sure knows we make it a
zero-sum game it's gonna be good
why do you say that oh it's like when
you have so like wind you have two
countries and one more advanced than the
others and the more advanced will take
advantage of a little ice event one and
it's gonna be zero-sum game
so is there a way I can make it not a
zero-sum game yeah yeah yeah it's yeah
that's so important to always make it a
positive sum game and to also share the
something as simple as we all reside on
this planet actually I'm interested to
hear what you think about this do you
feel like a lot of the issues that we
have in our world are because of our
disconnection from nature from source
from what sustains us well I haven't
really spent a lot of time on it I think
one thing that I see here is that a lot
of problems it will work on actually not
problems they're very incremental
privileges so somehow people here is
trying to work on things to make their
life easier and shy away from problems
and I can truly help a lot of people in
the rest of all first of all like almost
1 million people still don't have access
to electricity that's a real problem no
reason like nothing dear 1 billion yeah
yeah thank you
I believe that's also how many don't
have access to clean water it's a you
don't yes or something like that
yeah so like a lot of it somehow um yeah
I think is these are problems yeah
incremental privileges which is yes so
yeah yeah I know so like for example of
the blocking garage is there something
I'm really excited about okay I'm I
don't I don't invest in cryptocurrency
just to behave as a disclaimer I just
it's just like a lot of arguments on the
cryptocurrency people like I carry
currency it should help people who don't
have access to the world financial
system to actually enjoy the warm
pressure system because like simple a
minimally too far from commercial center
so they don't have access you legit have
a bank account and the bank cannot serve
them so the think cryptocurrencies can
help it can have them also Kyoto
currencies come raise their own base and
in bay area in Berlin it's like if you
really want to help those people who
have no excessive magnetism then why you
base
we're not basing like Ethiopia or
something so yes mm-hmm
yeah it's interesting and then also yeah
like you're you're almost describing
like this idea of like a virtue signal
in a sense of wanting to showcase that
you're doing something for the world
when it's just in an incremental
privilege in some ways but people also
come to places like the Bay Area or
Shenzhen or Berlin places because of the
network effect - that they can surround
themselves with other really you know
big technical leads like yourself I
didn't call myself you are you are you
know - when you're here you get to
surround yourself with people like you
but if you're you know you it's hard to
find someone that knows about tensorflow
in Ethiopia you know these types of
things so is there been a lot of
progresses in my training just because
of the availability of courses online
sort of thing people like a lot of work
in Ethiopia have accessed you yeah and
then I guess um interesting I think it's
a good thing like to surround yourself
with people who are like always having
our problems and we trying to like Sonne
things but there's all like the same
thing like when you surround yourself
with people who think too much like you
there's a danger in it as well yeah yeah
it's it's in many ways become like that
in the echo chambers that we've been
split up into and oh my god a little
bubbles are preventing us from yeah
hearing that yeah that's that's good
that's a good great point
let's you mention this I want to see
what we can discover from this what was
it like being born in a village
southeast of Hanoi what was that like
wow this is very funny so it's very
funny so I went to this dinner party and
this is like she is like
like 70 and she was like can you believe
so she was telling her story like
growing up and she was like she grew up
being like some other country names like
can you believe that when I grew up we
had toilet with no running water it was
like just trash in our toilet you and it
was like that's my generation story so
so it's very funny it's like people
think a lot of our thing is like
unbelievable like 60 years ago it's very
applicable to my like house house how I
grew up I grew up good I know flush
toilet this is no TV wet tea very late
I have obsessional internet so very late
we used to sleep on the floor and we had
this like terrible fear this really
silly I don't even wear worst and it's
like what it's like just sleep on the
floor because I grew up and I had this
fear still of like having warm crawling
yeah inches a year
are you asleep yes so that's something
you've never had to worry about anyway
it's not it's not a terrible actually it
was very free like I didn't grow up like
kids with like iPad yeah it was very
free yes so I grew up my running
barefoot
in there like rice paddies yeah yeah
which was you free very very people
don't understand that it's hard to like
explain it's just very different I ever
knew everyone I guess it's to choose you
every villages yeah it was somehow like
my parents
it's hard for my parents to imagine the
life I'm living right now because it's
so different from the life the usual so
I think it's a good signal that was like
I managed to like get out of it but it
is always sad and I think when I talk to
my parents and my brothers they can't
relate to my life anymore
you know everything's really said I wish
I could help
this way it was shame or yeah we just
had another episode when when we were
talking about one of our friends
we'll also went from a village in Kenya
to Nairobi hard to Harvard who's that
and so it and so he goes when he goes
back to the village he can't relate yeah
people in the village like any what
happens very yes I guess is the same I
feel like I think for him as a same
story to everyone going from a third
world country to a very privileged
bubble yeah yeah Wow what we're making
like incremental changes for privileged
changes yeah there's a solving
real-world prompts yeah that story about
a woman that said that Oh back in my day
we used to not have toilets and you're
like we still sleeping on like dirt
floor when I was a kid when you worked
here we have like problem house now so
this is good yeah Eddie was not so the
thing is like it's so horrible but the
thing is of like really feel poor when
you compare our such other people but we
can live in a village and everybody's
the same as us then it's as if we don't
feel poor just feel like oh we're just
normal is just how life is supposed to
be and it doesn't make it obsessed so
what's talking a little bit my friend
we're walking like on justice wholesale
home homeless people and my friends and
I was like oh how much more make missing
me if you're really sad to see them like
that my friend was like
I bet they have like better access to
health care since our parents did when
they were kids and it was like yeah but
like my parents didn't have to compare
themselves to other people they saw like
driving by in a fancy car this is home
as I would do and this is a comparison
that makes them like mix life even worse
so when you're kind of freerunning in
the rice pet the rice fields and you
have like the you have a hierarchy
that's a little bit more like a header
Archy it's like more flattened it
wouldn't like oh no in a village yeah
versus when you start seeing cars and
you see the immediate differences in
cars so you see the immediate
differences in people's yeah homes and
things like that then there's the
comparison mindset which can be both
extremely mentally taxing but it can
also be something that kind of motivates
people to maybe strive for something
like strive for a purpose but I also
totally resonate of just you know being
with life and just being just being
alive versus needing to go and you know
make money and yeah yeah as a rat race
yeah oh you came to the heart of that
the heart of the productivity culture
well yes that's very funny but are we
gonna like feel awesome
well what yeah I mean tell it will tell
ya let's we'll get there in a little bit
actually why don't you tell us about how
you picked up your interest because you
have you found it free hugs Vietnam
rides volunteer opportunities for any
students to help improve English you
organize workshops competition speakers
use all these types of things yeah how
did you pick up these interests growing
up and doing that I'm over in person
person a what an important important how
does that I
I am pol impulsive yes I'm an impulsive
for you so so easily like I'm not like a
big planner I don't plan to make my life
years in advance
okay yeah so so easily like I'm just
like huh this looks like a reasonable
thing to do let's just do it so the free
half thing my journey started when I was
in high school and I went to a high
school like far from home and it was
like really where I was living myself
when I was like 14 15 did you go to like
a high school that was of academic yes
yes yes kind of what similarly with what
Tom did I think is this easily like I
just think about like how people get out
of there I'm not a racist book was this
guy who has his theories that anyways
doesn't matter I'm just started going
through this theory but easily like it
has a different level of income anything
you can easily make next generation is
really moved one step further
but is there are some I feel like from
my parents to me like it's like three
steps and I'm sorry for this guy so
easily for that there's only a very
narrow niche way that it can happen in
today's rule to jump that many yeah yeah
you're like income gap
so Oh anyway so yes it was in high
school all right
and it was assault like getting sad and
money and you know in in Viet in Vietnam
or don't hug people don't express the
feelings we're looking at me like that
I'm a big hugger yeah oh my god it would
not have an outlet no I wouldn't need to
sign up for free thing happens in
certain areas of the productivity
culture is it's a it's a handshake or
instead of you know I don't want to hug
people because in my like sue you for
sexual harassment
that might happen to some people I don't
know um wait I shouldn't make joke about
that
okay this is so scary anyway so it was
just like learn about like express the
feelings more more so watch this video
of this guy who was doing free hugs
Australia oh yeah
he's such a corn corn so let's just do
it so I wrote a blog post about it and
it sort of went viral and it was like
the nicest do it so we did that so it
was just like got people together and
like we had this a free hugs campaign
she biet nom and after that I got like
so many in a contact from people like
mostly young people and I feel like
let's do something with it
and everyone wanted to learn English
back then people like English education
was not really like events and was not
you know their enemies and meet other
people so like let's just use this way
to practice English for English club and
then I how about other soft skills okay
so that was like things important way
things it's like you to have a practice
so we I realize a lot of NGOs coming to
Vietnam need help with translation so
sorry I can't take a lot of NGOs for an
NGO when they come to Vietnam and ask
hey do you need volunteers and then it
measures something like people so nice
to them who can help them there's a work
zone yeah
yeah and not only increasing the amount
of people that are willing to you know
be vulnerable or have that deeper
emotional connection via love a hug and
being a more popular but also yeah it's
when you're kind of like you know
wherever you're you know be a birthplace
is and then if it's in a country that
has smaller amounts of like GDP or
people and it's harder for them to
negotiate with the bigger countries and
stuff it makes things a different it's a
different completely different essence
and in a village versus a metropolis
especially in a city like the Bay Area
or yeah versus maybe even Hanoi yeah I
haven't been but oh hey not not really
good food yeah and great people the food
of the world of people of the world
cultures of the world yeah yeah it's
important to be in love with we love
tulle on to live on 6300 it's also a
flower yeah yeah yeah
yes well name of a cave it's a cave -
yes it's a cave oh we have one of the
world's biggest cave it's very big
you can fit an amped-up entire empire
snake go in the cave huh in the K you
could fit the whole player staple yeah
yeah that's crazy he's so big has his
own ecosystem sweet yeah that's what's
up see I want to check that yeah see
these are cool things in the world -
yeah
Sports Awards like kind of amazing it's
it's incredible this whole place you
can't explore it all in the lifetime go
away sure you can
what you need is like a big budget even
then you couldn't even explore Vietnam
in a lifetime you could explore the US
in a lifetime you can Chiklis they can
like go to on a checklist you could do
like 10 things in every country in a
lifetime maybe if you're lucky you could
get to that yeah yeah okay but then
after that this part was like okay so
you went to Brunei for three-day
vacation which turned into a three-year
trip through Asia
I told me I'm a sick person not not a
good planner at all
yeah so it was like after high school I
was like I know what to do with my life
you know um I already start working in
high school and it was like it's okay
it's possible to make money without
going to college and it was so
disheartened by there by the education
system in Vietnam and I was like I don't
want to go to school here sounds best
there must be good courses in Vietnam
anyway so I was like let us like trouble
and see so I went to Brunei for three
days and I had my return ticket but then
I met this little girl who wasn't
driving to like East Malaysia and she
was like wanna come with me it's like
okay sorry wheres like oh wow it's
really easy to just like go from what
countries annexed so it's like how about
we just try to do it so like let's try
to like go from a country to the next
and see how far I can go so it's the
worst case is when I like get up try to
get back home and it just kept on doing
it for three years
just kept happening people would just
bring you as a hitchhiking and I can buy
spa's ticket sometimes I should fly
because I'm sure when I have money and I
pick up something odd jobs on the road
whoa yeah yeah I was a true Namit where
did you go after the East Malaysia um I
wasn't like the Rosen's like sorry Asia
yeah like was Thailand Singapore yeah
and then then I went to India and Nepal
of course we have not go there like
searching for myself no he was not such
a know myself I was like he's all the
way but you know your life purpose huh I
did not I know I went to college who
like people so much younger than me and
this seems to know exactly what they
want to do with their life and I had no
idea why I should've been meant to it
you were too I forgot after India Nepal
then yeah yeah so spend some time there
and then spend some Israel and Palestine
I spent three months in Israel is so
much fun yeah also Palestine as well
mr. Issa was happening there the
conflict like a shot an in Palestine you
what happened you were shot at yes Alice
died and then as then I'd pick up some
like ammunition shelf just like as a
souvenir reminding myself that's late
alive he's precarious um then I went to
Africa
it's my mostly in Africa is anyway you
go in Africa
oh it's just like a long sea is the East
Coast yeah yeah so like since Annie Alex
like it'll be a Kenya Tanzania yeah
those are beautiful places yeah um it is
it's very different life yeah it's very
different way of life you feel safe
amongst the whole period of travel it's
funny I felt so much more safe in Africa
than here
in the United States yes a hitchhike for
a year in Africa is fine I try hitchhike
in a neon blue cookie and almost got
kidnapped oh whoa
yes not I don't yeah it's actually weird
I feel I felt so much more safe there
that's interesting yeah yeah yeah okay
and so then after this three year for
travel you got South America then yeah
after that then college where'd you go
in South America
oh I travel slowly like a cantina Chile
we'll leave you as a own very big
country yeah yeah then you felt good
there interesting it was all like just
ferry mind-expanding the whole this
whole process
three years ago it got old it did it got
old
yeah yeah I saw a ball like with travel
for like ten years
ms so many people was its natural father
life like for the entire life whoa I
made a lot of like week-old I'm like
this is my baby so when people travel
and then hit baby so this is those
babies like grow up on the road on the
road yeah it's really incredible they
were camping but the most of time in in
South America we spend more of our time
is like camping I was at camp and for me
like is exciting but any solace it's
like babies like 102 years old and just
owns our lives I've ever known it's like
it's living in tents sleeping in tents
on the road yeah yeah this is so so very
different
whoa yeah but then it got old it was
like it sounds fun
else first I learned a lot Reb for three
years I felt like my learning curve I
flat out much like from traveling yeah I
felt like so comfortable that's being on
the road and say okay nice time she'll
learn something different yeah yeah
just put yourself in a completely new
environment yeah
so then how did you do just apply to go
to see it's funny
so actually apply to Stanford before
travel you're gonna reject it
oh wow you traveled and they accepted
you yeah so Pai traveling help oh yeah
yeah I don't know I can import info
correlation from like culture for my
agent so in computer science classes and
masters actually came in because I
rewrote some books as a Tom oh you were
writing I wrote I published books for my
struggle in Vietnamese yes so all four
of them no - - was it I don't - books
when it was enjoy the books when I was
in a car in college so so I was like my
name is kind of fun maybe I should
become a writer like so so I was
thinking of doing something like Korea
Friday and I and I did took a lot of I
did take a lot of courses on it but they
also took some CS courses come to
science and it was really fun so just
kept on doing it yeah you were just like
CS is fun it's the future I want to be a
part of it and you just kept itself kind
of like taking the courses and itself
teaching yourself along the way - yeah
got a lot of help yeah it's just it's
just a possibility it's just cold you
can't create things it can make
computers do things for you yeah it's
really my blowing yeah make computers do
things for you kind of sounds like
humans being made to do things by other
forces as well yeah yeah that's a that's
a that's a whole nother I trust machines
model here
you trust machines weren't even yeah
they're predictable who does not
rational some they're not rational yeah
yeah okay I think I'm making a lot of
controversial stuff no I I think these
are interesting we have to be careful
whose programming these machines that's
all we do
whose programming us and our behaviors
and how rational are you do you feel
like you have free will
well you feel like you have for you well
Wow oh I would not try to get into that
son debate we have we're in charge of
each other so it's just a set I feel
like I tried not to get into those
existential crises fate like after
reading all about like how like we
actually liked Horace's we actually
vehicle for our genes expressed like
chili yeah so and we're just like
nothing everything is decided to like by
our genes
you just make me feel like then why not
exist I try not to get into the school
bus that's the doctor lived in his heart
yeah yeah you know did you know about
that doctor that there was a heart
transplant woman had reoccurring
nightmares about being murdered and they
said well who started this and it was
someone's that was murdered
hmm I think I mean as well and you know
they look stiff stiff yeah what is that
about it's about her about so it's a
really great book about al-qadir like
death like what happened to you're
either dead and also it's a so do you
find out what what does death mean I can
just like breathe that like hard dad you
know there's some research about with
cadavers what would they do with
it's really fascinating book yeah yeah
like sort of categorical it kind of ears
are useful research what kind of
research do ya like what happened is the
body when you just like very into the
growl yeah and also like cremation yeah
interesting thing is like mob it but was
also did an amazing job when make is
written it's interesting you wouldn't
never expect a book later be
entertaining but yes
I wonder what Eva Medina guest and then
so then okay so here you're getting so
deep into CS that you end up teaching
tensorflow for deep learning research
yes yeah I mean this is like this is a
big jump from the village
I know teaching tensive oil things like
this happen in the world it's so crazy
okay I think I'm classic we live in the
wall that allow for like change like
that should happen yeah so what happened
is I didn't it's I'm so I'd really glad
that I went to stand for it
I think this offers a lot of academic
freedom I was walking into you know as a
Tom tensorflow
is you know what has a fully endorse of
machine learning yes a cool for people
to train and deploy the machine learning
models so I thought it was very new and
documentation as a time was not very
good which is pretty true to every like
engineering product people don't spend
enough time on documentation so why did
you learn it and I couldn't really fight
good resources so like it's gonna be
really cool we have a course on it so I
can also I can learn it together with
other students and I talked to some
professor it's like oh we don't have Tom
do you like create a new course it's
nice so much work and I was like okay
let me get a [ __ ] and they're like okay
so you took up the initiative to create
it yeah so like here's a course and in
Tartus yeah so you're just learning from
the limited amount of document
and that was made on on it and then you
would then try out a better teacher give
examples yeah I got a lot of help I got
so much help yeah yeah yeah you had
people that helps you out yeah and she
taught how many students did you end up
not much we got two student taught
licensure cost so through them through
their own paste online now our nose is
of course nice the first time it was
offered so was like Chinese people so
it's a it's a cap how many one yeah yeah
it's still a lot of them because so much
demand because the first time I was
offered we'd receive my 250 applications
for any sport yeah so like the second
years they were like let's increase the
sigh that's of course there's any bigger
but I was like I'm a full-time student I
can't take I can't I kind of take a big
course silver second year with only 40
students and then I got into course
stuff to help me I still like yeah yeah
what better way to learn than to
synthesize the edge of machine learning
programming and then teach that okay
people I think I think just somebody
it's a sum up someone's set this like
when one person teaches two people learn
mmm yeah that's good one person yeah so
I've learned from it if they have an
open mind yeah yeah I think it was a
learning process
so that's what I was like when I want
you to learn something I should try to
explain that to other people
likewise yeah yeah so option is the same
thing I was like I want to consolidate
my knowledge and machine learning so
let's write a book on it so yeah and
that's that's your your you're showing
people how to succeed with interviewing
for machine learning positions Laureus
succeed I feel like I don't want to
think interview as a sanitized test
signal so entering interviews series is
like very much a sanitized recess and
that problem with standardized tests
give standardized answers they get
people who like think the same way any
forceable should prepare for that mm-hmm
so sinners test makes standardized
people yes so damn yeah so I'd also like
people don't have time to prepare I I
feel like I like learning brand sold
I don't like learning just so I can pass
some test I want you to learn something
so I can use that in in to some problems
I care about so yeah I don't like
preparing for Senate dice some
engineering tests because a lot of
things I learned there can be of no
application to me and it give address
over to have time to prepare like a lot
of students like people who don't have
my jobs and spend a lot time preparing
but simple actually having a job right
now so they don't have Tom to like
prepare so for me I spent a lot I have
been spending a lot of time talking to
like companies to see how they hire
people how they come up with questions
machining is very new in any industry so
of course like AI stuff has been like 70
years history but like applying AI a
machine learning in in my production in
algebra tiles is very new things and you
have read about like how the 40% away I
saw actually not bad
not being a ass 40% of AI startups
aren't doing it yeah it doesn't have
human to do it well it's fascinating so
so so for hiring for this sorry problems
that machine learning can have solved
but if companies don't have people
knowing how to do it so having a higher
people if you have really good in-house
machine learning team then these people
can help you like Valerie the next
candidate but you don't have ones and
how can you hire the first motioning
person so a lot of companies don't know
how to it just might from my impression
right mark thank you thanks Ron solar so
something don't know how to do it and
say and they try to rely on like weak
signals know whether the person went to
a fancy school whether the person I work
at a fancy company or I had a big-name
professor and so I was like the only
small group people who fit that bill
whereas there's so many people who might
be really good at but if we didn't have
a good interviewing pipeline she like
correctly accessibility and people the
company's afraid of hiring those people
because they can't evaluate them yeah we
could read this is your upcoming
yeah yeah and then so then what what is
it like can we can we get some of these
examples of AI applications you worked
at a bunch of companies leading up you
worked at Netflix primer bum Moy you
helped is that how I say bow my family
it's a news aggregator news aggregator
and it means not knocking venom it's not
we won't miss monomial like there was no
any speaker she liked to tell you that
it's a bad name when your name it like
that no that's a cool name
and I'm second most popular web browser
20 million plus active users yeah yeah
yeah it was a it was a side project
beginning they were first like a way to
engineers going on it so at first the
company and it's like focus on company
different product no it's a really to
engineering on it and then also I helped
with like market research and trying to
like figure out a what people want from
a browser what so what features include
and then figuring is a go to market
strategy so it's oh I have to launch it
and then the now in video but but but
what about all yeah give us these AI
applications yeah that are were that you
were working on across all these
companies so my team are the media is a
very new team it something about you a
year old so we we help companies bring I
had research to productions easily so
you know like Academy I kinda make care
about very different problems sick guys
right beats benchmark so it doesn't
matter as a more extremely complicated
extremely cosmetic trade and so I'm
going to beat some benchmark but it but
in a real war companies gave are very
different things it goes with
Wednesday's more always easy to the
Train easy deployed quick to inference
you do inference so we try to be used to
toolkit to help companies do that easily
to deploy training production
yeah so one problem we have is open
statistic which is a framework to try
and stick on a second model so first we
can do like speech recognition machine
translation sending analysis is based on
tensorflow
and it's really helpful because it
helped where did you betray me so you
know so you want to train the models on
multiple machines is the same time again
it's faster but also my training on my
machines cost less a lot of problems so
you want to like create a framework to
make it do it without problem and also
we want so it allow for mixed precision
training if Emily was a term mixed makes
precision training mix precision
training yeah so easily when you
represent like a piece rate you like
when you represent a float floating
point number with like three two bit so
so first of all if you have like
billions of parameters if we it to make
cost native memory wise yeah so if is a
way you can reduce a precision instead
of using a 32-bit to present represent a
number yeah can we use any 16 yes you
can use any half the memory how do you
do that it's possible do it but then in
so costs I'm like routing arrow we're
gonna make some some values can be very
tiny and when it's so tiny when I round
up to like 16 bit it becomes 0
okay so we have a lot of techniques to
deal with it so basically we have this
framework to to have you do like the
addition is for tuning and make present
raining and we have my pre-built model
step pretty cool and you were giving the
examples of speech recognition yeah we
have this special she's just open Jasper
yeah okay so so it is it consists of
very simple component and it has a
really good performance so I think we
think it's a good baseline model for
companies you like just like using
production because it doesn't require
and it comes complex topic other context
technique so we're talking about me
speaking and then picking up the words
via audio what I'm saying putting those
in a text with a certain confidence this
is the sequence of words and then once
you have that then there's you want to
try and prove that that's actually
better than what the previous technology
so they have my standardized benchmarks
for you to compare for like other models
but even know like going from like a
benchmark less standardized like it I
said should be what it is that it's very
big it's a big step you're trying to
beat the old models with beat meeting
something mrs. Salwa competition but it
is a competition you should it be more
efficient though this is not a
competition this make it sounds like oh
these coming at you out performs as a
company and you have to be a winner I
think I got I think versus mode more
like collaborative and some we build
upon some collaborative his wife of
course yeah yeah yeah
but if everyone's going in the same
standardized way of doing speech to text
and
yes I think it's after company to
evaluate which system is best wasn't
meat because a system might be really
good like recognizing words nygel work
but Sonesta may be really good at
recognizing like medical terms for
example so really depends on underneath
as a company we have a we have another
example too of and it's not my way it's
not it's not it's not the work but I
think it's a really good example because
you also end repeat using it in your
class
this shows students like what is this
mine it was a big deal so so like I
think this is such that your firm stand
for it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
that's a research about how this group
of like estaba and just co-author I
think Brett so they use tense flow shoe
to detect classified skin cancer yeah so
I think my sole problem is that it
requires a trained doctor etymologist
a long time shoe detective
yeah different type of cancer you can
run millions of examples of and train
the models detective and then let the
dermatologists know then I think I think
they try the part of it as something
look like assist the Tamala gist in
making decisions yeah yeah Anthony was
on par with table-like dermatologist
yeah yeah it was really cool research on
by like how using machine money do you
have this and then it was a real world
application yeah yeah because a lot of
people don't have access like your
hospital maybe will not close to the
hospital if there's always gonna
temperature of the skin and they
immediately faced dangers and just goes
a doctor right now and then mine I make
the trip my children my show and some
years
Hospital present bushel candy treated
and I just what we were doing with India
in India with some ideas machine
learning to help provide to help people
like detect different yeah I do yeah the
medical applications are really
important and these are the these are
these this is why we when we really talk
about the different applications I mean
medicine is such an important industry
for it it seems like a lot of the
cutting-edge tools are being used to
still gaming and and film and for
cryptocurrency autonomous vehicles these
types of things I had built things up
like machine learning is just a tool and
there's so many things you can use tool
for I basically it's like machining you
say a hammer everything looks like a
nail right now everything looks like a
nail right yeah yeah and maybe some
things is real it's good to use the
hammer on and some things that's maybe
not so useful to use it on right now
yeah I think it isn't so problem with
hyping up like machine
right so a lot of companies they were
like oh we need to use the AI for our
company I can't ever know what to use
there for things in these views they are
whereas a lot of the problems can be
solved with more statistical tool like
techniques so this is just a free Adele
side of of like all this hype about
machine learning because you know Thomas
vehicle has to take in their inputs of
the cameras on the environment and then
have to make decisions based on vacation
and then I mean it's still complicated
to run the different computations that
that cryptocurrency needs to run I mean
I don't know much about that recurrent
see you right now
but yeah but instead driving car ceramic
or is there a big use of machine
learning I'm so excited for it because I
don't have to have a license so why
didn't you get a driver's license I'm
lazy yeah and then uber is like leaf
unlike everywhere I don't know how to
survive it will burn lift anymore
I'm so dependent on technology this is
it's interesting I'm so dependent on
technology I don't Auto live anymore
Wow what we do like we're going to
grocery stores and not growing our own
food we're so dependent on our computers
and smartphones what would we do without
them
I say things like all of this
technology's just make a privat
traditional solutions my and it is my
god I could have like got a taxi in the
past I was an own just like uber lyft
make select acts a system cat go update
it and don't a sitter are not driving
taxis anymore so we can't even like just
a picture circle
you have the amount of applications I
think that is being used a hammer to the
nail hopefully some of them are
maximizing our connection to nature
connection to what do you want to
connect to nature so much why yeah it's
where we come from okay but it has a
theory if everything crude by nature is
nature then human is poor duck of
nature's and anything that we create is
nature put in my two cents yeah you know
I love the city and you're looking to go
into nature get away from the city and
get closer to nature up there and
wherever yeah and as I'm in the city
amongst all these people it's weird
moving shrubbery you know moving trees
where nature to the city there's nature
in this the urban jungle I know it's a
weak case I got a good case in a buff
lawyer but I need wine isn't it though
it's not the case though that if we're
continuing to make all the algorithms
that make our world a machine metropolis
centers then
is that still connected to the origins
of our essence it feels like it's very
disconnected from the Lord okay so wait
how about origin how far back of the
origin you want to go back we can just
think about creation and then having
what we have now like because the time
we see had no clothes
beggars has had no clothes at all
yeah well yeah well technology creation
is technology a creation is art it's a
big big art experiment a big tech
experiment what's happening I feel like
every generation we have this
glorification of the past it's like a
look was a pasta was a very romantic
lens like ah we are so far from the past
but then why I feel yeah as long as as
long as it's being done moving forward
in the future in a conscious an
harmonious way yeah if it's moving
forward in a destructive dystopia way I
don't want to move into that why not
just go fasten your seat belt
I agree that's like I got a wand I
wouldn't I wouldn't want to like enter a
future where there is more of like bad
things than good things Maria and so I
had such a complex topic because what is
good and what is best very subjective Oh
like sorry yes subjective it got it good
for one group of people can be better
another group of people all right what
is good for like one species may be bad
for another species like I don't know
what if like most she nationally
eradicate human race actually really
good for the planet Earth then
like I'm like I suffer from longshore
just make sense of crisis
well how many ephesus and philosophers
and moralists work with AI programmers
right now hang a lot I think every
company a lot of companies are hiring
like AI safety researcher and I think a
lot of like havea rhetta's like trio
recently like how old it tech pcs talk
my field also first mm-hmm
there was just like yet tech VCS it's
like don't talk about tech and just talk
about like I could look hard and he and
you know get and any sort of payoff I
just talked about like Jarek life advice
and philosophy I feel like everyone's
turning to philosopher nowadays
that's great in many ways that's great
yeah because then you can go back to
these questions what is good what is
love what is truth these questions are
really important if they don't have
answers and we're programming some
future but the thing is just like we can
afford two things about those questions
because we don't have to worry about our
basic needs which have been taken care
of by technology you can also think
about those questions and live on land
and just be in that setting over here
okay no hungry 24 right well if you have
a rice if you have the food on the land
that you're another hungry 24/7 of
course when I was a kid I spent a lot of
time thinking about what food I would
eat once they had money
there's a lot of time on it because I
worry so my parents didn't leave me
hungry
but Zig zig zag like give me enough food
to eat but then there was only desires
like this really good things I want to
eat but then we cannot afford it so I
spent a lot of time thinking about like
hmm what food would spend money on first
yeah there's a complex calculation that
happens between what desiring war and
also realizing that you don't want to
materialize yourself you want to dien
materialize yourself you don't want to
get stuck in hedonism just seeking
pleasure Wow
you know what's food good food you know
is expensive hmm
yeah there's there's a bunch of other
ways to phrase the point yeah why is so
complicated well that's why that's why
it's also it's also beautiful and simple
- it's both that's many of the you know
the paradox and all right let's do
let's do what I think is one of the
coolest things that I think you did you
got into trouble because yes
wai-wai-wait let's bring it up let's
bring it up and explain it okay so so
this was a little over a month ago you
did Metro Twitter what Twitter reveals
about the differences between cities and
the monoculture of the Bay Area and okay
so then I just want to kind of just want
to jump to it this post consists of long
sections data how people in different
seas describe themselves what people
talk about a unique emojis in each city
the most unique city and a conclusion
and so basically what happened was you
got users from the 13 areas that are
listed here in you Anna Austin the Bay
Area Boston Chicago DC LA New York City
Seattle Melbourne Sydney in Australia
Toronto in Canada and London in the yeah
it's like touching major
english-speaking country other cities 13
major english-speaking cities and this
was just a number of users and tweets
for each city but then this starts to
like the author is like so like I got
also users outside those cities and it
is it's like distribution of like where
they come from where they come from you
up okay and then tweets by ear in the
Bay Area how people in different cities
describe them so it's like YouTube BIOS
so being apart is like how people
describe themselves so chip would parse
the Twitter BIOS for keywords and then
make word clouds of the most popular
words being used and here's something
interesting a sad thing to note is that
love is prominent in all cities except
Washington DC some of the common words
in DC BIOS include opinion view and
tweet which come from disclaimers like
tweets views opinions are my own so if
we so be ready if you see the word tweet
that's what's that's coming from but how
people in London describe themselves
I got like London view music founder
love writer world director so it's like
there's a good combination of life
like tech founders and said like music
yeah and they have the director writer
bulk I kind of like yeah and then and
then this is how people in the Bay Area
described themselves
yes very tyke oriented so okay so I got
a lot of like at least the word love
shows up yeah okay yeah I got a lot of
problem for the guys are trouble for
this why because you've all will like
I'm happy with it so first of I can tell
you like first of all I'm happy with how
I got the data they were like oh you're
not allowed to script people I prefer I
like to it was like it's not public
information people are sensitive it's
public information and and also these
are and when I first reached out to you
I said that we have so much useless
information about there's so much noise
going on in the world
and to be able to run projects like
these whatever percentage of companies
forty percent of companies that say they
do AI that don't do AI etc that you if
you use the hammer for nails that aren't
even meaningful I think you're using the
hammer for really meaningful things here
because when you make a word cloud like
this of how people describe themselves
it gets people to think wow well why is
it that we use like there's there's
examples here that I want to show like
people in the Bay Area describe
themselves with tech product design
engineer previously that's my favor yes
we are saying producer actor writer TV
and this is another example where DC
national reporter News Polly subjects
when it come on is I think this shows a
differences between two cities so that's
why it says burying everyone and also
for those that don't know with word
clouds the larger the word the more
frequently it shows up the smaller the
word the less we see frequently it shows
up in Seattle to Amazon Microsoft game
love okay and I just want to show
there's lanta okay this one in Austin
the words love husband mom music social
software Southwest
you know what a life yeah I just think
about the word love coming up more in
the Bay Area or mom or dad or family or
life you know these types of words you
know why is it that we're so obsessed
with building things that are that are a
pet that are outside of us and the
deeper more emotional relationships are
almost put a backseat to in a sense
we're like a mimetic fountain outward
and a genetic sink there's like very few
babies being had here worse whereas like
the middle of the United States is
having all the babies you'd embarrass a
good place you have babies it's a hard
question it's not a binary answer where
it's a good place to have babies if you
got financial stability
coming up when I talk to my friends they
were like ah hummus and I'm here for my
career but when I'm ready set it out
have family I don't want you I have a
family here you're just so comparative
you yeah yeah and especially but
somewhere like yeah it's really
competitive here there's like a plus
side of like Oh your child would you
know compete with other you know
potentially kids that are smart in
certain domains but also at the same
time it's a massive
the rent is very unstable here it's very
high the the connection the nature can
be good if you know if you maybe like
live on Ocean Beach or if you you know I
should think Tata for has a pretty good
has proven accession nature yeah but
people are stuck people are programmers
that move here that have never been to
the ocean before and they literally live
in the akan doz in the downtown and they
have never been in ocean you don't know
that I do because I used to actually
talk to them and they used to say that I
haven't been there yet it's been a year
where people that say I've lived here
for years I've never been a Tahoe you
know I mean it's still you know yeah but
there are also people that I know that
our programmers that have been out there
every month it's totally true they also
surf or their programmers AI ml people
and they go and they do you know
parasailing or whatever they do so many
different things so anyway there's tons
of different to diversity people that do
things in their own ways but just if
you're if you're not consciously using
this hammer of AI and machine learning
and you're not connected to nature
you're not connected to your birthplace
you're not connected to family or
friends on a deeper emotional level like
if you don't know how to hug right if
you you in you're building AI is there
probably a problem with that living
house your hug yeah if you if you or hug
is just one example how about do you
know how to look at someone's eyes for
30 seconds oh my god what do it yeah
because all of a sudden you'll notice
that like you have a deeper more
profound experience with the person if
you've never looked at someone's eyes
for 30 seconds or if you've never asked
them about what their core values or
their core ethics are or if you've never
asked them about you know what their
purpose is in life or like how they feel
emotionally about who they are in this
world and what their partner's like all
this type of stuff it's just weird
do we actually get into those kind of
those conversations and those deeper
more spiritual more emotional
connections to each other will end to
nature will drastically help with the
way we build our future okay the helping
affectionate is those characterizations
well like we were describing earlier if
there's actually philosophers or more or
less or Issus entering into these
companies and working directly with
programmers if at least if people that
are programming and designing tools also
go to things that where they can
practice things like emotional toughness
when they can go to into the forest or
to the ocean when they can go and
practice like circles of of conversation
where you get deeper into the emotions
of each other
yeah I think um there's one thing to
notice here it's a lot over here like in
the air folks at career like I think I
might say with somebody here for my
career but if I just choose not because
of my job I'll bring out here I'm gonna
promote me here so over here like thing
of here when they hear is a fight mode
on it's like you say like go get things
so don't have time for things that like
don't directly help the career it may be
a lot of questions about life universe
love just don't fit in the morning is
really sad is that s is so many it's not
only it's just not it's a didn't come
from me actually is from like what my
friends have told me they told me that
like they've seen so many young talented
smart funny people and their own single
not only name man like women you just
like people don't have Tom you date to
date they're working on their career
yeah this is like definitely feel casual
they're trying to spread ideas yeah
they're they're trying to spread ideas
yeah doing a date would take time away
from me spreading my ideas but other
people say that if I date then I gain a
little bit more
bethey and emotional intelligence and
then it helps me spread the ideas better
if you have everything has a yeah just
seems like I don't know who's talking a
lot about this like what makes somebody
a friend and want me to make it look
quite end and it seems for me like so
great all the conversations with like
other people because ever I think it's
just not just me I'm not sure you feel
the same way but it's just like certain
kind of like deep personal connections a
lot of things on the surface like you
yeah you meet a lot of people every day
I meet a lot is this great you have a
lot of ideas like oh yeah you should
work on this idea what this company is
doing this way and I stopped friends to
raise money for this and it's really
exciting but then it's really hard to
get a deeper like I want you to know the
more like what are they worried about
don't talk about how quickly to you when
you meet with someone how quickly can
you go to the depths of who they are
yeah because if you stay at the surface
you don't get to if I wanted to keep on
like hey I'm cool I'm making it I have
no problem it was Bill fred or his
showings of Wick the witnesses this is
my like harm them as a courier
yeah and this is will be good to follow
up on more than another conversation
together I like I like the project Metro
tritter I have no idea of course if we
move we move fast if you guys do check
out the Metro Twitter project that ship
did it's it's it's really strong and
it's and I and I hope this inspires more
people to make projects like this it's I
think it's using the hammer of machine
learning in it this is not really like
Michelle he's my statistical statistical
method statistical method techniques so
it's but if you do i do oshio should be
very careful with data like for this
like I am anonymized everything I do
myself
yes so there's no like revealing
information about energy but if you
scrape like 100 of thousands of like
users you should read very be very be
very careful with and also like data is
bias as well so I think a lot of this
like people unhappy with this some some
people unhappy with us because I think
that like this did I collect a choice
very by this data so the weather is
biased data it's very biased as in life
like people in different cities might
use studio for different purposes first
people in Austin might be uses like just
you like it's a strong media tours
express himself but wouldn't bay area
might use as a networking talk sure sure
so so yeah so like they that can be bias
so just keep in mind when were you do a
project this is fair data there's okay
that this difference is with statistical
methods fair bias with data fair yeah
I'm safety with data yeah all very fair
important things but do projects like
this because just being able to see
visualized data that can teach us more
about philosophy or ethics or the way
that we actually can progress in a
better way I think I think that's what
this project did for me I think a lot I
learned a lot from even though I got
like some negative feedback I think I
learned from the feedback as well so I
think if you are like good looking in to
do some free time and is looking to
learned or
get some insight into something I think
good moving the data is a big way
yeah yeah I want to ask you two
questions on the way the first one is
are we in a simulation it depends on
what I defy simulation is what do you
know define us I think we are like I
think one is finishing in our own head
Jim I think it's something I read a long
time ago about a universe is personal
Mike was a purple might not be from the
same as my football we might recognize
the same thing as purple but what do you
think of as purple maybe different one
meeting I think it was a purple so I
think everything we see here like rusev
it's just riddle with our own personal
biases see anyway yeah we live in a
simulation our brain hmm and then what
do you think is the most beautiful thing
in the world
most beautiful thing in the wall Wow
I haven't thought about it let me say I
think it's human kindness strangers is a
random act of kindness is this making me
so happy I also cried when I see but we
tried really hard and overcome you ever
washed things like the race and just
cries the end because you see somebody
was like praying so much I feel like
when somebody put in owns as they have
to achieve one thing that is so
important to them I don't care what's
the one thing it's just so beautiful hmm
beautiful a t-shirt okay thank you for
coming on our show yes thank you so fine
thank you and we'd done I'm glad I'm
glad you had a good time you know let's
close the show right now and this is
funny that we did the hug because it's
another project free hug projects around
the world get started with those as well
good good I'm glad to hear that and
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below in the
episode let us know what you're thinking
also go and have more conversations with
your friends family people online social
media co-workers have conversation with
people online do it have conversations
people in person yes yes and also maybe
share some stuff that you find important
maybe online but talk to people about
the things that we talked about in
today's episode go and share more of it
around the world everyone and also check
out the links below we and chip calm as
well as her Twitter profile go and check
those out and thank you Ron Vargas for
producing and directing we greatly
appreciate it and also support the
artists entrepreneurs and organizations
around the world that you believe in the
spiritual leader support them help them
grow sports simulation our links are in
the Bible o patreon PayPal
cryptocurrency also design merch and get
paid go do that and go build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world we love you very much thank you
for tuning in we will see you suits
[Music]